okay okay we got it
keep your star pads on without the
rights to some of its most popular
titles and its biggest stars contracts
about to expire
watch Marvel Studios scrape the bottom
of the barrel for their obscure
seventies comic book that barely anyone
read proving once and for all
we'll see anything if you slap Marvel's
name in front of it guardians of the
galaxy
Suda for Marvel's attempted Star Wars in
a science fantasy adventure about heroes
you've never heard of Starling who
protecting a planet none of them live on
from an underdeveloped alien village
whose problems you couldn't care less
about we're really region aired this was
a fun movie journey across the galaxy to
meet this gang of lovable misfits
there's Captain star-lord
from America the human leader from a
different time in place like Captain
America Gamora the Black Widow ish
leather-clad female assassin like Black
Widow Drax the guy with the killer ABS
who doesn't understand our customs in a
Thor kind of way Groot a big hulking
tree get it and rocket the wisecracking
tech genius with a drinking problem like
Tony Stark what I'm trying to say is
they're the space Avengers but I guess
it's technically not stealing at the
ripping all themselves
watch the Guardians race to find an
excuse for more Avengers sequels by
chasing after the Infinity stone and orb
of world conquering power that no one
bothers to guard and a gem so powerful
it can kill you just by touching it
unless you're this guy or you can join
hands to disperse its power unless
you're these guys or you can just jam it
into a hammer and use it safely from
there it's best not to think about it
too hard you thought the Avengers was
nerdy you ain't seen nothing yet
between all the action and comedy get
ready for a whole lot of space
mumbo-jumbo I will unfurl 1,000 years of
Kree justice on Xandar what's important
now is we
get the Ravagers army to help us save
Xandar so we could give the stone to
yondu and the remnants of these systems
were forged into concentrated penis then
if you can figure any of that out try to
figure out why this blue alien isn't
working with this blue alien who's
working for this blue alien to kill this
green alien who both want to kill this
purple alien as dustless christmas
coloured alien but if you've been
confused just remember the hero is still
the white guy so experienced the swagger
of a movie studio drunk on its own power
as marvel trolls the world with false
out middle fingers to the audience they
know they have in the palm of their
hands oh you like superheroes well how
about a movie that stars a king raccoon
and a king tree you like Vin Diesel yeah
well we cast him and he only says one
King why'd you want more petty greed
actors will put them in stupid outfits
and make them safe space [ __ ] all
Nova pilots interlock and form a
blockade because who doesn't want to be
in a [ __ ] Marvel movie hey recognize
that chubby idiot from Parks and Rec
we're gonna turn him into a sex symbol
that would be hilarious remember the
worst movie ever made Howard the Duck
stick that after the credits when
everyone's expecting Avengers 2 it'll
totally be with our fans and they'll
love it anyways
speaking of which remember that nose
from that one scene at the end the
Avengers a few years ago well we're
bringing him back and he's still not too
in sheet why because we're marble that's
why what are you gonna do watch DC
thought so
starring Marvel Chris number three three
materi Drax on Drax off-chip Barca the
key
Blue Man Group dr. steve brule and
darkside
Marvel's Space Avengers okay I get where
star Lords Walkman came from but where
do you get a tape deck for a spaceship
galaxy Shack be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers hey screen junkies
want to see the coolest swing set ever
built then click the box to the left to
see our friends at superfan build
surprised at guardians of the galaxy
superfan with their very own Groot swing
just tell them the epic voice sent you
you've said it yourself [ __ ]
we're that guardians of the galaxy I
like pie pie is triangle shapes donkey
teeth there has been an awakening have
you felt it the dark side and the light
babbling bumbling band of baboons these
pretzels are making me thirsty